[Music]
let's go to liz in charlotte north
carolina what's up liz how are we
hey dr don i'm blessed to be strapped
how are you you're blessed to be
stressed
that is
maybe one of the worst best rhymes of my
ever ever you should be a rapper ratatat
so what's up
so
my husband
three and a half years wait wait time
out time out time out i just got that
i'm blessed to be stressed
that means you have like a job and
you're
you've got kids and stuff so things are
go okay i got it i'm blessed to be
stressed i like it do you have that on a
pillow somewhere in your house
so i have it on my computer printed off
of a label maker of course you do this
one of the teachers i had in high school
had it on her computer and it's just
been something that always
resonated with me so i i love it i think
you should get it tattooed on your wrist
i think that's really cool kids get
tattoos these days all right so now
we're back so what's up your husband and
you and then what
okay so my husband of three and a half
years brought to my attention uh
recently that i am not the beneficiary
on his life insurance policy what i
don't think that he's gonna die tomorrow
um
he might if he doesn't if you don't if
he doesn't put you in the middle who did
he please please god tell me he put like
an old girlfriend please please please
please
why um our two and a half our
two-year-old daughter
is the soul
on the policy
why
i don't know that's one of the reasons
why i'm calling i guess to
try and
figure out and have a discussion with
him um so when he told you this what did
you say
um i kind of thought he was joking
and then he went on to be like oh you
know i'm putting it and if anything
happens to me it'll go on an escrow
account she won't be able to touch it
till she's 18.
and then it kind of just got my brain
circling and thinking like
again no i don't think you're going to
die tomorrow but
but hey we have a house he might
yeah
right so i mean yeah two big red flags
for me
can i tell you the biggest red flag is
not the one you think
the biggest red flag is you have been
together three and a half years how
long's your date before that
so
about two and a half okay i've known him
for about 12. six years you all have
been lovers 12 years so
he tells you this
something in you didn't immediately
start
causing a ruckus
why did you stay quiet when he said that
that that is the worst possible
financial decision he could make unless
he doesn't trust you he's planning on
leaving you doesn't want to have to deal
with a lawyer later
um
giving
he's just gonna leave his life insurance
money for 18 years if he dies tomorrow
and then you just gotta raise this kid
with no money like what that makes no
sense but
before that why didn't you say anything
i think that's kind of just been the
whole
uh summary of our relationship again i
kind of thought he was joking
he had mentioned before we got married
his brother his stingy brother was going
to be in charge
and then we got married and had a child
but this is not our only child um i have
a daughter from a previous relationship
that he adopted
after we got married okay
eight and a half
does he not want that kid to have
the money
i think it's the first part of your
sentence he doesn't want that kid
but he adopted that kid so that ship
sailed
i know
there's other issues i'm telling you
yeah
i
for sure
uh there's other issues
hey i don't i don't mean to be
ah man
no please be because we've seen a
marriage counselor your marriage is in
big big trouble is what i'll tell you
big trouble
100 agree with you okay
big trouble and
he's either having conversations about
you and his situation
with other people and that's where he
got this advice
um he is
creating hell in his home by adopting
another child
marrying somebody who had another kid
but trying to
cut that kid out of his life
and which is just gonna
wreak havoc on your family
um on your biological kid on this
adopted kid on your marriage every i
mean what a mess
and then that
there's a hard thing to have a
conversation about and this doesn't even
sound like a hard conversation to me but
there being a hard conversation
um
you can't have it
what's at the root of this thing
we've
i guess everything in our in our life
and our relationship has been
100 miles per hour since we began
our relationship he was in one before
for about seven years i was previously
married
and have we haven't slowed down pumped
the brakes the entire time how'd y'all
get together
so we met in college
uh
about 12 years ago 11 and a half 12
years ago
um he was in a previous relationship i
was in a relationship i ended up getting
married
ended up having a child ended up getting
separated uh due to infidelity and
divorce
on your part on your part
on his part uh yes and so when
my husband and i
we kind of rekindled through social
media
lived in the same town basically growing
up um and then we
i was an adult then but i was always
taught that
like with divorce my parents have been
married for about 35 years now but
if it's not broke you don't you fix it
you don't throw it away but after three
different times of infidelity from my
first
husband i just couldn't deal with it
anymore
and so we got divorced and again i
rekindled with my
now husband is he cheating
my husband yeah
i really hope not
you know the answer to that question
it's a yes or no no no okay um
here's the here's the deal so to answer
the original question yes
the only
thing that makes any rational sense
whatsoever
is that you are the sole beneficiary
and then your
two kids or the
your mutual beneficiaries and if you
have a life insurance policy which you
should even if it's a small one he he
should be your sole beneficiary
and there shouldn't be any discussion
about taking care of these children
and i think my wife and i set up a trust
so it goes into the trust so if we buy
things whatever it all goes into there
and it gets distributed at a certain
amount but
um
even the folks that we have that if my
wife and i were to die our kids would go
to a couple
they have full access to that money and
here's why i wouldn't have picked them
if i didn't trust them
to take my children and a lot of people
will put more emphasis on who's what's
the deal with the money than they do
with who gets their children
but i trust them and so they may need to
build another house they may need to
move they need to get another car they
need to do whatever
and i trust them now i'm going to have
money for my kids college and all that
but
um i
yeah this signal is a mess this signals
somebody who's either about to get out
of a relationship this signals somebody
who doesn't like the current
relationship that they're in is trying
to pick and choose parts of it but it's
a bigger signal that you all are not on
the same page
and you got to get on the same page you
said you all been running and gunning
and running and running and running for
seven years
are y'all just gonna run off the edge of
a cliff if you're not careful
how do you get that back how do you stop
and just say whoa whoa whoa let's we
need to talk
uh we've seen a marriage coach for a
little over almost a year now uh
in a year y'all have not
received any coaching on how to get on
on skills on how to
stop in the middle of a hard
conversation and be vulnerable with one
another
that means your mirror therapist is
terrible
if y'all been seeing them for a year and
you don't have any tools or the courage
or the strength or any of the insights
into
having a hard conversation terrible
do you think
no it is
again i thought he was joking it's
but then i'm you know rethinking it over
and over again and i'm like well if
something does happen to him
it's like i'm gonna have to move not
only am i going to be grieving my
dead husband but i'm going to have to
move
our two children because i would have we
would have to sell the home if i'm not
on this policy
and i did bring it back up to him
and he was like
you know well there's ways to get around
her being the only person on there
yeah there's one
you write it down
oh my gosh yeah so
you all need to have this conversation
asap and i
if you need to go back and see a
marriage coach there's something you're
here
are you safe are you an abusive
relationship
mentally
more than physic definitely not
physically but mentally he's
definitely said some things that
um
[Music]
have
shot daggers to the heart and he doesn't
understand the
he thinks that it's all okay that he can
just apologize and it'd be fine the next
day but then these things keep being
brought back up and give me an example
of one
um
i didn't marry you because i loved you
um i married you so that we could adopt
child's name
and i didn't hear this until the
adoption was final in
july of 2018 and i didn't hear this
until our
about a year ago
so does your husband he was the one who
brought up the the
divorce
i've never brought that up until about
the 10th time when i was like you know
what i can't
take this
like how many times are you gonna say it
before it actually becomes real it mean
that he wants to get a divorce
correct yeah
that
going back to the very first thing
without knowing that his actions tell me
that he's got a foot out of this deal
that just doesn't make any sense
at all
at all
and by the way you want to ruin your
child's life give all of your money to
one sibling and not the other
killer great idea
unbelievable yeah so
y'all
this is a lot liz and so here's what
i'ma tell you
um
i'm just gonna rattle off three things
off top of my head okay
have you seen somebody on your own
yes
how's that going
um it was our same
counselor
and it was
due to
he kind of gave me an ultimatum if i
didn't see somebody
by myself by that date
are you are you
are you stable are you okay
am i okay uh-huh
like what and why would he give you that
ultimatum
because he's
not a nice person
why do you think so little of yourself
liz
who told you this is what your life was
worth
he did no before him somebody told you
before him
uh probably my ex who cheated on me
multiple times okay
i want you to go see a different
somebody
somebody who's going to pour into you
and walk alongside you
not just doing stuff as you kind of work
not as kind of as you work towards
healing
you got two little ones that are
watching everything
and you look at yourself in the mirror a
few times every day
and you're just simply worth more than
this
i see it every
listener on this call is gonna hear it
anybody watching this is gonna see it
and you don't see it
and you're worth more than this
and so the first thing i want you to go
work on your healing you got to go talk
to somebody and say i need to heal and
i've been
emotionally beat up by a couple of men
and
i deserve more than this and i don't
even know where to start
the second thing is
is you need to
write this stuff down for you get out of
your head and get on a piece of paper
these things that make you feel not safe
and if my husband's got secret money
accounts if he is giving
life insurance money to our baby and not
to me
um there are some major trust issues i
wouldn't feel safe in that situation and
i know i know i know there's other stuff
going on here
there's the things he says to you like i
don't even love you i don't even know
how we're married except for this kid
what whatever it happens to be
i want you to write this stuff down and
third you got to have a hard
conversation
not in the fight but don't set it up
that way but you got to go somewhere and
be on top of it
and be direct and say
your comment about or your decision to
put all the money in in the hands of an
18 month old or a two-year-old
um broke me it's about enough
and you tell me you didn't get married
because he loved me you tell me you're
gonna divorce me divorce me divorce me
to voice me yet
you're willing to leave me destitute if
you pass away leave me and our other
child destitute or all three of us until
you got to see all that stuff out loud
then y'all have to decide if this
marriage is worth going forward or not
because right now it's not now it's a
mess
and i want you all to stay married but
you're gonna have to
lean into this
and i want you to walk with a
professional because something tells me
you're not telling me the full story and
something tells me that you're really
struggling right now okay
we're with you liz
go see somebody make that call today
this is the morning so you got all day
to make that call and not the one you've
been seeing make a new call today